but every theory and I don't want to
jump to any conclusions or anything like
that but if I can make an observation
[Music]
so Tenley's a movie starring Melissa
McCarthy and I shouldn't have to say
anything else because by saying that you
know what the movies about and like
seriously I think Melissa McCarthy movie
is going to be a Netflix category in
about a month but in this particular
Melissa McCarthy movie Melissa McCarthy
she's kind of down on her luck she just
got fired from her shitty fast-food job
so she goes on a road trip with her
grandmother played by Susan Sarandon
from there it's Melissa McCarthy who's
the funny lady in a roadtrip movie holy
it's almost just like the last one
but it's not exactly like the last one
she's not a criminal in this movie but
for the entire movie that's what I mean
when I say it's a Melissa McCarthy movie
now you know this movie does have some
stuff working for it first of all
Melissa McCarthy she's talented she's
good at what she does she's good at
comedy she's good at ad-libbing but at
this point I feel like it's Jim Carrey
in the 90s you know in the 90s we had
Jim Carrey movies and Chris Farley
movies they get typecast and they do the
same over and over again because
they're really good at doing that
that's Melissa McCarthy now we have
Susan Sarandon you plays her grandmother
I actually enjoyed Susan Sarandon in
this movie she was a likeable lady she
had some life - okay that's cool she
works well with Melissa McCarthy's they
don't have the chemistry that you want
them to have but they still have good
chemistry
it's like goodish chemistry that also
gets an award for wasted potential
chemistry and I don't put that on the
actors themselves I put it on the
writing mr. ridings a little awkward and
off at times between the two of them
you're like okay they're getting along
and then there's at least one scene in
particular where Susan Sarandon gets
drunk and starts mouthing off and you're
like oh that is no I'm not having fun in
this comedy which I already wasn't
having a lot of fun and fully the
dude that's right the romantic enter oh
my god I almost forgot about him because
the reason I almost forgot about this
dude who's in the movie to play the love
interest - Melissa McCarthy's character
because he's so nice and just like oh
god you know I just I'm a responsible
guy doc golly he is so that guy that he
is forgettable he's the kind of guy in a
room and gathering full of people he'll
be in the background and you won't even
know he's there he'll be thumbing
through the photos years later you'll be
like who's that guy
do you know that guy I don't know that
guy and he's the possible romance for
Melissa McCarthy that we're supposed to
root for in this movie like who was the
guy what's his story where does he come
from
nobody knows I don't think the writers
of this movie know they're just like
we'll just have a guy in there
why not the movie has a couple of
heartfelt moments one in particular
actually likes it's dialogue between
Melissa McCarthy and this one older lady
and I liked it a lot in the end his
movies directed by Melissa McCarthy's
husband to have a Melissa McCarthy movie
with Melissa McCarthy in it that is a
Melissa McCarthy movie at this point in
her career and life in general be great
to see her do others share what she gets
movies like this because she's good at
doing movies like this this movie
ultimately is a sloppy roadtrip movie
with a couple of people and along the
road trip they do shenanigans and they
run into situations circumstance and
they do the thing everything from fake
armed robbery to getting drunk and
possibly and banging somebody it's not a
movie you have to rush out there and see
because as for Tammy it's a movie you're
not gonna remember in t-minus a couple
days yep already forgot about that guy
especially who is that guy so what is
your favorite roadtrip movie of all time
not police trains and automobiles that
is cheating yeah yeah I know up up down
down left right left right B a start
codon this whatever your favorite
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]